I want to take a one-point seven meter
fishing rod 1.7 meters that's about
beginner how to do that here so that's
the ground I'm I think I'm 178 roughly
okay so that's there I want to take out
a board buses the drive says that the
longest thing I can fit on there the
longest length is a meet-up okay so what
can I do now I've heard some suggestions
I think I'm gonna discuss at fault I
heard it suggested cut in half or get
burn more money so you can buy like one
of those telescopic ones that I may be
wondering what this have to do with
Pythagoras theorem and the answer is
everything so underneath your diagrams
they are two diagrams I would like you
to draw for me a cube a cube here is my
cube complete with a cool invisible
edges that you can't see but I put them
in dotted because we're gonna need to
look at those okay now remember this bus
company it's rather draconian and it
only allows one meter objects into the
bus right so so I'm gonna take on this
box which is one meter by one meter by
one meter it's a perfect cube okay do
you see where he's going okay so I'm
gonna put some measurements on here I'm
not gonna put one meter on every single
edge because then I have numbers and
letters flying everywhere I'm just gonna
put in what I need okay so draw with me
or write with me rather one meter and
one meter on these two bottom edges
there are good good excellent well you
can see here that even though all of the
edges are one meter if I put objects
inside this they don't all have to be
straight they can be like I know at
different angles so you could fit things
in up different sizes the question is
how big okay so for instance if I put an
object and I lay it down on the bottom
the bottom of the cube bottom of the box
okay so made it down like this
stretching from diagonal from corner to
corner
across the diagonal okay so clearly
that's the biggest object I can fit on
the bottom so it's laying flat okay now
hold on a second
how long is this green object I can work
this out with Pythagoras card I let's
let's have a good good you got al even
though it doesn't look like if there's a
right angle there right because it's a
cube
writings everywhere so I can write out
Pythagoras theorem to work out this
length let's call it oh I'm very
original I'm gonna call it X okay X
meters is the leg
well what equation should I write with
Pythagoras I should write the sum of the
two shorter sides sorry the sum of the
squares of the two shorter sides that's
equal to the square of the longer side
yes track it so far
yeah so one squared plus one squared
what's one squared it's one so I have a
big complicated number to work out over
there okay so it's two so that's good so
that means the actual length is not true
though that's the square of the leg so
what's the actual length I can write
that exactly as a square root of 2 which
is 1 point for approximately okay sure
that's great I know what this length is
right unfortunately 1.4 meters is not
quite long enough to fit my fishing rod
is it okay yes so maybe way up should I
draw this line okay so he's from the
Detroit if you have another color this
would be really helpful because you got
a lot of lines firing I'm gonna draw
this okay can you see that bottom corner
above this green diagonal but it
stretches all the way up to the top of
the box okay that's what I'm putting
stuff in now again I have another
right-angled triangle doesn't quite look
like it cuz we're we're looking at it
from an angle but the right hand goes
right there
there's writing and I know what the
sides of this triangle are I worked at
the bottom side the base if you like
it's the square root of two
what's the vertical side equal to one
cuz it's a cube
very good okay so now I'm gonna work out
the red line how do I do it what
equation should I arrive
1 squared ok now I could use the decimal
couldn't 9 yeah but we're better than
that
we know what it's equal to exactly and
that's what I'm gonna write now let me
see what's happening ok now I need to
write something over here need to give
this red line a name I'm gonna be even
more original and call it whoa hey okay
so I'm gonna call that that's the
hypotenuse so that's Y squared okay one
squared you guys already told me that
before and I have a very good memory so
that's one right now what's this thing
what's this thing it's a square 2 times
square root 2 which square root just
means if you square it you'll get two
right it's gratitude I screwed you and
you can check it on your counter okay so
that's wise so now I've got Y squared be
equal to 3 that means Y that long red
line over there is a square root of 3
which if my memory serves me right is
about one point seven three and then
there goes my fishing rod way the hole
three centimeters to spend